[Musique]
bonjour à tous c'est le grand retour de
si on parles sport sur
tv78 pour ce grand retour pas de
changement si ce n'est ce nouveau
plateau il y aura comme toujours des
analyse technique des décryptages et
surtout une dose de bonne humeur pour
m'accompagner nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous sur ce plateau et ils sont en
pleine forme présentation en musique on
commence à ma droite musique c'est le
tlier de cette émission il pourrait
parler pendant des heures de sport il
adore le cyclisme mais il s'intéresse à
tout notre champion du monde de cyclisme
sur piste Masters notre capitaine Yan du
Jarrier est avec nous pendant une heure
bonsoir Michel comment allez-vous Yan
champion du monde ça fait longtemps
maintenant je crois qu'on peut oublier
champion du monde Masters master on peut
oublier maintenant c'est fin on oublie
c'est fini vous êtes content de revenir
sur ce plateau ce magnifique plateau qui
a changé très content comme vous dites
en pleine forme après bientôt 3 4 mois
qu'on n pas qu'on est pas venu donc
repos long la POS festivale a été trop
longue c'est noté on continue à gauche
musique vous reconnaissez ça musique
c'est notre Colisée notre tour de PIST
tout le monde veut nous l'prendre il
sera bien avec nous cette saison sur le
plateau de si on parle sport notre
Italian lover Gregory canal est avec
nous pendant une heure il a résisté aux
sirènes venu de l'Arabie Saoudite
comment allez-vous bonjour bjour écoutez
très bien très content de pouvoir
reprendre avec la team si on parlait
sport j'avoue que la pose estivale a été
un peu longue la cantine a étit bonne
donc là on est content de se remettre au
sport parce qu'il va falloir revenir en
forme pour aborder cette saison
d'ailleurs j'ai un petit cadeau pour
vous mon portable avec le petit
chronomètreronomè
je sais que c'est très important pour
l'mion pour exa parfait merci beaucoup
et les sirènes venu d'Arabie Saoudite
Grégory non c'est le moi c'est la
passion du sport avant tout et pas la
passion des dollars et des euros voilà
les pétrro dollars parfait merci à vous
à grégoryi d'être présent sur cette
émission on repasse de l'autre côté
musique il entame sa deuxème saison sur
le plateau de si on parl sport il est
devenu au fil du temps un titulaire
indiscutable il est aujourd'hui
indéboulonnable il est responsable
sponsoring chez Orange en Île-deFrance
il aime le sport il vit pour le sport il
est amoureux de sport ladies and
gentleman Philippe volac est avec nous
pant bonsoir tout le monde très très
plaisir comme les très plaisir de
revenir ça m'a manqué beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup je arrivais même plus
à dormir la nuit tellement je disais
c'est quand ça va recommencer c'est
quand et puis voilà et le jour J est
arrivé avec un beau plateau c'est c'est
vraiment voilà on est un peu perdu parce
que voilà mais c'est tellement beau que
voilà et vous avez manqué aux
téléspectateurs on a reçu de multiples
lettres de fans à votre égard donc j'ai
commenc à répondre
voilà ouais c'est ça on termine de
l'autre côté musique qui n'a pas encore
sorti la peau de bête mais ça ne devrait
pas tarder avec des températures qui
commence doucement à se rafraîchir il
adore descendre dans l'arène de ce tô
qu'il défend ses idées avec ardeur notre
gladiateur Pierre Chevalier du Rugby
Club de versaill avec nous forme et
bonheur comment allez-vous pi c'est
sympa chez vous c'est sympa et on est
bien on est bien c'est c'est fait avec
beaucoup de bon goût de technique vous
aimez ouais c'est magnifique le son ai
le son trs son son on est on est on est
en pleine pleine possession de moyen
technique on a on a upgradé là sur CNN
78 alors avant de passer au programme de
l'émission on va parler rugby et de
cette Coupe du monde en France qui
s'achève ce weekend avec une très belle
finale Nouvelle-Zélande Afrique du Sud
les All Black et les springbx se sont
entraînés pendant cette Coupe du Monde
du côté de Croatie sur scène la
Nouvelle-Zélande avant sa demi-finale et
l'Afrique du Sud avant le quart de
finale contre la France la rencontre
contre les springb est programmé ce
samedi 28 octobre à 21h au Stade de
France avant de parler pronostic
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
installations à poissi qui ont reçu
quand même quatre équipes hein il y a eu
les Tonga l'Afrique du Sud la
Nouvelle-Zélande et l'Argentine
maintenant pour sa petite finale
qu'est-ce que vous en penser scè sur scè
on va en parler dans quelques instants
ben écoutez non c'est la preuve que les
evelines sont une terre de de rugby on a
l'occasion d'en parler notamment avec le
le Rugby Club de versaill je pense que
on aura l'occasion de dresser le bilan
de cette Coupe du Monde qui de leur côté
ont accueilli le le pays de Gal non une
terre de rugby une terre propice aussi
pour préparer de belles épopées de beaux
matchs alors ça fait mal mais en tout
cas les springbx ont pu préparer leur
match face à l'équipe de France et
peut-être que ça les a mis dans les les
meilleures condition prépar voilà ils
sont bien préparés un peu trop
d'ailleurs et bah les All Black derrière
pour se qualifier donc en finale il
préparit la la demi à croiss sur scène
donc non on peut que s'en réjouir
d'avoir des équipes de de haute factur
dans les iines qui ont pu s'entraîner
dans les iines Philip vola qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez ah ben moi je j'ai vu
aussi des reportages ils ont été au
contact du public en plus ça je trouve
que c'est très très bien de pas rester
enfermé un petit peu moins pour les All
Black hein parce qu'il préparit la
demi-finale mais les autres équipes
ououi voilà ça mais avant et tout ça
donc je trouve que c'est que c'est que
c'est très bien je dire et puis je me
dis bon il c'est le rugby mais ça
prépare aussi il vientura sûrement pour
les Joos aussi des équipes qui vont
venir des sélections qui vont venir
aussi dans à à croissie je pense c'est
même sûr ouais donc je trouve que c'est
que c'est bien et ça donne c'est c'est
enfin tout même tout pas que les Blacks
he mais partout ça ça a drainé quand
même je veux dire le le le rugby ça l'a
bien montré hein je veux dire Pierre
Chevalier crooss sur scène vous
connaissez oui oui oui je j'ai j'ai
visité les installations et c'est déjà
une c'est déjà un site qui est bien bien
identifié comme site de préparation
sportif il y avait eu le foot il y a pas
si longtemps pour les pour les féminines
euh et puis c'est c'est souligné en plus
le le très gros travail qui a été fait
par France 2023 pour l'organisation de
cette Coupe du Monde on pararlera du
sportif un peu plus tard quand ça sera
un petit peu mieux digéré mais sur sur
la partie organisationnelle événement
moi j'ai eu la chance de de vivre ça de
l'intérieur avec l'Écosse mais loin de
nos bases loin loin de l'Île-de-France
c'était c'était côté de Nice du côté de
Nice mais là on a en Île-de-France comme
la rappeler Greg on a on a des des très
très belles installations il y avait il
y avait le RCV avec les le terrain et
les et la capacité hôtelière mise à
disposition par la ville de versaill
pour le pays de Gal croissie avec les
Tongas pendant le pendant les phases de
pool et après en ce qu'on appelait les
les match City team base donc c'estàdire
les les les les lieux de villégiature ou
d'entraînement ou de préparation pour
pour les matchs et donc c'est ce sont à
la fois des infrastructures qui sont
faites pour et puis il y a surtout aussi
tout toute toute la la partie humaine
évidemment les équipes sont sur place
euh pour accueillir pour faciliter la
vie des équipes et Philippe l'a rappelé
oui les les community engagement
c'est-à-dire la quand une équipe qui est
qui est en résidence à un endroit vient
au contact des écoles de rugby des
hôpitaux des écoles des maisons de
retraite et donneent un peu de leur
temps et et leur image pour pour
justement faire profiter de la Coupe du
monde à tout le monde et ça je pense que
ça a été une une réussite dans les neuf
les neuf villes hautes stade et camp de
base ça montait jusqu'à 20 20 camp de
base pour les 20 les 20 équipes à noter
que croissie sur scène porte chance aux
équipes généralement qui foulent sa
pelouse parce que la Coupe du Monde
Féminine il y a eu les États-Unis qui
avaient foulé cette pelouse les
États-Unis avaient été très loin la
compétition il avaient gagné la
compétition et là on a deux finalistes
finalement qui se sont entraînés à
Croatie sur scène dans tous les sports
d'A un football pour les États-Unis et
rugby peut-être là on le verra y gerier
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous vous
app entendu encore sur la question non
alors ce que j'en pense c'est que en
effet ça montre juste que en effet notre
les Yvelines sont une terre qui permet
enfin en terme d'herie d'infrastructure
de pouvoir accueillir ces événements et
c'est cool pour nous parce que bah on
peut profiter ils ont fait de gros
travaux d'ailleurs pour pouvoir
accueillir des événements internationaux
comme cela bien sûr mais donc voilà bah
là maintenant on en a la preuve et c'est
et c'est mis en place maintenant ce que
moi ce que pas ce dont je parlais mais
le côté sportif et là c'est plus
l'extasportif que ce que Pierre disait
c'est que voilà les les joueurs de très
haut niveau bah ils jouent le jeu pour
bah pour aller au rencontte du du public
et aujourd'hui c'est ça qui va qui va
avoir donneré la réussite de cette coupe
du monde parce que ben justement il y
aura des gens qui s'intéressaient pas
spécialement au rugby mais du coup de
fait d'avoir rencontré ces athlètes puis
bon quand on les croise hein c'est quand
même des c'est quand même des très beaux
bébés ben ben on les a croisé bah du
coup qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va
vouloir regarder le match derrière et
ben c'est une un effet de boule de neige
donc ben plus de plus de d'envie d'aller
au stade bon là c'est pour les pour les
vrais pratiquant mais ensuite ben des
des des plus novices Ben se
s'intéressent au sport et euh et
apprécie le apprécie le spectacle du
fait d'avoir pu rencontrer ces ses
athlètes et là sur sur les images qui
passent en même temps le il y a la
spécificité du rugby et d'une coupe du
monde où il y a cette cérémonie de
remise des Caps donc des petites
casquettes qui qui représentent une
sélection en Coupe du monde pour les 33
joueurs de des délégations euh
présente et ça c'est une cérémonie
publique organisée par le porteur donc
par la ville le département la région au
au bénéfice je dirais de la de la
population population locale qui va qui
va justement à la rencontre et qui voit
ces athlètes débarquer passer un peu de
temps parce que généralement les les
cérémonies d'accueil sont sont plus ou
moins longues à la ville de Versailles
c'était c'était le 3 septembre avec une
délégation du Rugby Club versaill qui
était qui était en moyé d'honneur de de
la délégation galloise et et un peu de
temps donné par chacun des athlètes
staff plus joueurs à l'ensemble des
spectateurs et des des fans de rugby ou
de ceux qui ne connaissent pas et donc
juste finir en disant il y a beaucoup
d'autres sports qui devrait prendre
exemple là-dessus parce que en effet il
y en a on va parler du sport phare entre
guillemets le sport mondial pourrait un
peu redorer son image là-dessus sans
citer le football bien sûr sans citer le
football CIT prononcer
n j'ai gagné mon pour conclure sur cette
thématique un pronostic pour cette
finale autour de cette table
Nouvelle-Zélande contre Afrique du Sud
qui va gagner greégory on commence par
vous hein vous allez peut-être
inspirerè non mais moi les c'est vrai
que les sudafricains m'ont quand même
largement impressionné depuis le début
de cette Coupe du Monde il y a eu des
des gros matchs en face à l'Irlande au
premier tour bah face à la France c'est
un gros combat un gros combat physique
mais quand même voilà j'ai pas envie de
leur porter malheur moi je préfère voir
les les All Black s'imposer aussi par le
contexte on les donné pas vainqueurs don
tu dis les BO non voilà c'est par ou non
mais les Black serait la belle histoire
on les donnait vraiment pas vainqueur au
début de cette compétition il y a eu le
premier match perdu face à l'équipe de
France en en ouverture et ils se sont
révélés au cours de la compétition il y
a eu un quart de finale juste sublime
face à à l'Irlande donc j'ai quand même
envie de les voir briller d'accord et
gagn donc la Nouvelle-Zélande pour vous
Grégory on va dire les springbx pour pas
leur porter valeur Pierre Chevalier
préparation la tactique et la montée en
puissance des blacks en phase de poule
et en début de phase finale je dis les
Blacks de 9 points les blackes de 9
points ah oui c'est précis Philippe
volac les Blacks de 9 points 8 points 7
points plus que ça je pense au moins de
15 points 15 points ah oui facile ah oui
facile y du gerrier je vais dire les
blacks et j'espère d'un
point j'espère d'un point comme ça juste
les Sud-Africains comprendront z pas
digér la défaite je pense B vous
connaissez mon côté très Chauvin et en
effet juste là pour parler pour parler
sportif ouais et puis après il a y a
aussi le côté c'est tellement beau quand
on peut battre les Blacks mais c'est
aussi tellement beau quand on les voit
gagner donc c'est aussi pour ça que que
je mais bon voilà ça sera le match sera
dev le match avec unee samedi voilà
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler du nouveau centre
d'entraînement du PSG à poissie il y
aura aussi un débat sur la nouvelle star
de la NBA livinois Victor wembanama
est-il prêt pour ses grands débuts mais
avant de parler de ces thèmes on va
parler
[Musique]
football en football donc on va parler
du FC Versailles qui évolue en National
le club Évinois qui est reparti sur un
nouveau projet avec de nouveaux
investisseurs n'a pas franchement réussi
son début de saison les joueurs de la
City royale sont pour l'instant à la 9e
place du classement avec un bilan de 3
victoires 5 nuls et trois défaites rien
de grave on est seulement à la 11e
journée du championnat mais à la même
époque l' dernière les Versaillais
étaient au niveau du podium la question
sur cette thématique les Versaillais
sont-ils moins forts que l'année
dernière vous votez oui ou non
oui pour vous Pierre Chevalier partagez
non pour vous Philippe volac et partagez
pour vous y duarier ouais partagez on va
faire un petit duel entre Pierre et
Philippe Philiipe vous commencez non je
les trouve pas je les trouve pas donc il
sont pas moins fort que derni
non ils sont pas moins forts que l'année
dernière je pense que je trouve que le
championnat euh est plus équilibré plus
équilibré cette année euh plus équilibré
et je pense on en revient toujours on en
a parlé l'année dernière quand on voit
les stats sur les sur tous les matchs il
y a à
domicile il gagne pas il joue encore à à
comment à un match à domicile ils ont
gagné qu'un seul match à jeanoin
toujours pareil le même souci il jouent
pas chez eux c'est toujours jour avec
1000 spectateurs 1000 spectateurs loin
de chez eux et je trouve que voilà ils
ont ils sont ils sont ils sont pas moins
fort mais on aura toujours le le le
souci de du terrain et de jouer hors
hors de ses bases et ça je pense que et
on le voit encore cette année ça
pénalise aussi on le voit là on parle de
Versailles mais on le voit pour Paris FC
qui a été obligé de délocaliser ses
matchs à trois et ben ils ont pas gagné
un seul match en délocalisant ses matchs
à trois donc ça y fait d'avoir son son
terrain et voilà mais je le trouve je
trouve pas MOS fort parce que parce
qu'ils sont je crois qu'ils sont ils
sont 6e je crois et il sont 7e on va
voir le classement qui 9e place pardon 9
il sont à 6 points du 2è ENF VO à 6
points du 2è je trouve que c'est pas
encore versa à 14 points le Red ST est
par contre largement de
ave ils ont ils sont 7e exo mais Ben bon
voilà non je trouve qu'ils sont pas ils
sont pas moins forts et je trouve que
c'est c'est plus plus seré à part le
restar qui qui s'est qui s'est qui s'est
envolé pour l'instant ça fait penser un
peu que voilà mais autrement derrière
c'est c'est très serré paril y a quand
même de bonnes équipes quand même en
National cette année je veux dire Pierre
Chevalier alors moi je pense que c'est
répondez moi je réponds je réponds que
qu'ils sont moins forts mais vraiment
globalement structurellement
sportivement peut-être humainement
d'ailleurs aussi et que il y a quand
même un motif d'espoir parce que parce
que c'est pas c'est pas que ça me ça me
fasse plaisir qu'il soit qu'il soit
qu'il soit moins fort euh la lueur
d'espoir c'est c'est la la structuration
dans la durée finalement et et ce qu'ils
ont les décisions qu'ils ont prises
notamment avec l'arrivée de Perlade
l'année dernière quand je dis quand je
dis qu' sont moins forts c'est que c'est
bon au-delà du mathématique en en photo
exacte à ce moment de la saison cette
année par rapport à l'année dernière
c'est c'est c'est surtout sur le jeu
produit sportivement le groupe le groupe
en lui-même alors après là on n'est pas
dans les dans les secrets d'alcov et de
de vestia pour pouvoir êre être sûr que
que déjà humainement humainement ça ça
se passe mieux que l'année dernière eu
retour retour arrière sur le structurel
tu l'as rappelé c'est même cause mêmes
effets c'est effectivement ils ont pour
l'instant toujours pas d'esprit à
domicile il va simplement y avoir un
retour à montboron pour la Coupe de
France ça ça je pense qu'on verra la
différence 6 tour contre fur 8 voà donc
net très je pense que ça ça jouera ça
jouera son rôle là-dedans en attendant
pour un mat ouais pour un match en
attendant c'est toujours jeanbouin donc
structurellement euh moins fort ou aussi
aussi aussi défavorisé que l'année
dernière sportivement c'est vrai c'est
vrai que le que les oppositions sont
peut-être sont peut-être plus plus
intéressantes si on compare là aussi les
équipes qui étaient déjà dans dans cette
poule de national l'année dernière comme
martig par exemple et sur les premiers
matchs moi j'ai j'ai trouvé qu'en gros
les les copies rendues étaient moins
moins sereines on a on a du match nul du
match nul ilarve pas non seulement à
gagner mais à marquer également aussi
avec quelques 0 aussi qui qui sont venus
qui sont venus émailler le début de
saison et humainement pour
l'instant même si c'est cette lueur
d'espoir le le groupe n'apparaît pas
forcément ultra fort et et imbougeable
c'est toujours mieux que que que les
attermoments de l'année dernière avec
les tests fait par les différents
entraîneur euh le déjà en remontant
jusqu'au jusqu'au à l'air chibi puis
Chris euh et puis là là là je pense que
c'est un choix c'est un choix
intelligent le choix de de Perla de
l'ancien drodz mais mais là c'est
au-delà au-delà encore du mathématique
c'est vraiment cette impression de dire
qu'à priori avec un recrutement qui a
pas été forcément non plus hyper
flamboyant je les trouve moins fort que
que l'année dernière à ce stade de la
saison mais j'ai j'ai cet espoir que que
que dans la durée ça puisse se
consolider y gerier qui vous a convaincu
vous qui étiez indécis bah indécis moi
j'étais indéc tout simplement parce que
pour pouvoir savoir s'ils sont plus ou
moins forts c'est pas que euh des
statistiques ou des ou des chiffres
c'est aussi la qualité de jeu et pour
pouvoir juger la qualité de jeu faut
faut voir les matchs et et suivre suivre
les matchs de manière très très sérieuse
j'ai pas suivi les matchs des années
précédentes oui en effet il y avait des
résultats et il y avait une tu l'as dit
une équipe un gros noyau là on sait
qu'ils ont vécu une tempête l'année
dernière euh il faut pouvoir s'en
remettre c'est juste pour ça que je
disais que je suis indécis euh je dirais
que je suis plus plus du côté de Pierre
du faittait pas loin la montere he
finalement oui bien sûr mais sauf que
bah en effet ils étaient pas loin de la
montée et heureusement qu'ils sont pas
montés parce que sinon avec la tempête
qu'ils ont vécu l'année dernière ça
aurait été très très compliqué de
pouvoir avoir la la la continuité la
continuité cette année là ils ont vécu
la tempête ils l'ont passé quand vous
dit tempête c'est tempête niveau tempête
structurelle avec l'ancien l'ancien
investisseur qui qui du coup s'est
retiré en cours de en cours de saison le
promoteur immobilier est rien contre la
personne mais en effet le secteur
immobilier est très très très compliqué
depuis 2 ans ils sont toujours là mais
après ils sont minoritaires voilà il
minorir mais bon je veux dire voilà
c'est que économiquement il y a une
explication c'est pas c'est c'était pas
on peut pas dire que ils étaient venus
en disant on va faire ce on va faire
cela c'est que structurellement il y a
eu il y a eu un souci avec la avec la
conjoncture économique du du secteur
immobilier et ça on on y peut rien du
coup chance pour versaill d'avoir
retrouvé un un investisseur qui qui
reprennne départ et qui remett des
billes dedans avec un projet sur le long
terme donc là comme dit comme dit Pierre
remettons les choses en place c'est pas
catastrophique le bilan numérique n'est
pas catastrophique ils sont pas
relégables ils sont dans le milieu de
dans le milieu de tableau de quand je
regardais classement avant de venir
c'est deux victoires et ça y est vous
êtes vous êtes quasiment quasiment pour
la pour jouer pour vous jouez la montée
donc là c'est c'est un noyau qui est
très très très serré laissonsleur un peu
le temps de de pouvoir repartir et
remettre remettre tout ça en place gror
cont ils sont aussi à deux points des
premières places relégables moi je y a
beaucoup de relégables cette année dir
Mo il aégable cette année à partir de la
13e place jusqu'à la fin du classement
on descend dans le championnat de de
National 2 moi je suis plutôt du côté de
Philippe je pense pas réellement qu'il
soit moins fort cette saison c'est vrai
que si on fige à l'instanté et qu'on
regarde le classement après la 11e
journée il y a tout juste un an ils
étaient 2e du championnat national là
ils sont 9e mais après si on regarde
dans le détail l' dernière ils avaient
ils avaient que deux défaites à ce
momentl de la saison là ils ont trois
défaites on a quand même l'impression
que c'est plus sur les matchs nuls que
ça se joue l'année dernière on se
rappelle aussi les victoires ne se
jouaient pas à grand-chose c'était
jamais des 3 ou 4-0 pour pour le FC
Versailles ça jouait toujours à à rien
mais c'est vrai que cette année de la
même manière il en fallait aussi peu
pour que ça bascule en la faveur de
Versailles il y a eu beaucoup de matchs
nul cinq matchs nuls depuis le le début
de de la
saison je pense que c'est vrai qu'à
l'instanté on pourrait être tenté de
dire ils sont moins fort l'année
dernière Versailles bah était parti pour
monter à la fin de la saison ils sont
complètement écroulés moi j'ai envie de
dire attendons de voir à la fin de la
saison il y a eu un recrutement qui a
été
complètement on va dire à l'inverse de
ce qui s'était fait la saison dernière
là on parle de jeune joueurs un
recrutement qui était aux alentours de
je crois de 23 ans la moyenne d'âge
voilà beaucoup de jeunes bah il y a
laassana diakabi défenseur Martic de 27
ans qui est lui le plus âgé vraiment de
de recrutement romain basque romain
basque a 28 ans et laass diakabi a 27
ans sinon la moyenne d'âge c'est aux
alentours de 23 ans il y a énormément de
joueurs qui ont 20 21 22 ouis donc c'est
très je attendons de voir parce que
effectivement ça a été dit là
l'investissement est fait sur le plus
long TER terme je pense que sur le long
terme Versailles peut vraiment avoir une
équipe plus forte que celle de la saison
dernière la saison dernière le
recrutement avait été tourné vers des
joueurs qui avait déjà l'expérience de
Ligue 2 déjà l'expérience de nationale
et dont on attendait qui était assez âgé
la plupart des joueurs qui étaient
arrivés avait plus de 30 ans et on
attendait effectivement qu'il puisse
être performant d'ors et déjà donc sur
le point de vue sportif je suis pas
forcément convaincu qu' on est une
équipe moins forte c'est vrai que si on
fige à l'instanté allez on serait tenté
de dire oui du point de vue
organisationnel moi je pense que cette
année vers une structure un peu plus
établie je m'explique Alexandre mulèz
est quand même très présent aux
entraînements on a vu aussi dans
ça voit à chaque fois sur les photos les
deux autres investisseurs de l'année
dernière le groupe F du Sim City on les
voyait moins ils étaient quand même
moins présent et au niveau de
l'organisation on a vu aussi que dans
les premières décisions qui avaient été
prises au-delà d'annoncer les premiers
recrutements au niveau des joueurs on a
annoncé l'entraîneur on a annoncé aussi
le responsable recrutement on a vu que
au niveau de l'org organisation
peut-être aussi au niveau de
l'administratif derrière il y avait une
volonté de structurer un peu mieux le
club que ce qui avait été fait sur les
les saisons d'avant donc moi je suis pas
convaincu qu'on a une équipe moins forte
il faut juste lui laisser le temps on a
un entraîneur qui a du talent qui connaî
les joies des montées de national à
Ligue 2 qui peut faire du bon travail à
mon sens avec Versailles et on a aussi
des des jeunes joueurs des des jeunes
prospects voilà on parle de prospect en
NBA parlons-en aussi au football qui
peuvent peut-être montrer toute leur on
va dire toutes leur force dans dans les
prochains mois donc moi j'attends de
voir avant de me positionner
complètement il y a eu 12 arrivées pour
15 départs il y a eu notamment les
départs de Diego Michel à socho walidouf
anim capo Silva à châurou Dan delonet à
Cholet Inza diasuba à Borgo la fin de
carrière aussi de de Fabien Lemoigne en
on en parlait justement précédemment des
gros départs finalement avec des joueurs
un peu emblématiques qui qui faisaient
partie de cette épopée en Coupe de
France cette demi-finale contre Nice
finalement est-ce qu'on ça déstabilise
pas aussi un club aussi tous ces départs
vous venez just de le dire 12 arrivées
il y a combien de joueurs sur un sur un
terrain de foot il en a
11 effectif un peu un peu plus important
mais quand même quoi oui mais ça veut
dire que même si on a 22 22 25 joueurs
il y a quasiment la moitié du du du de
l'effectif qui a été qui a été renouvelé
faut faire revenir dokovic ah Joko
pardon
excusez-mo on peut comparer à on peut
comparer au PSG en fin de compte quelque
part le nombre d'arrivé le nombre de
qui n
n après le PSG a je crois signé des
joueurs avant l'arrivée de l'entraîneur
par contre pour le le coup oui et ça
veut surtout dire aussi que là avec le
nombre de départs qu'il y a eu il y en a
très peu ou beaucoup moins qui ont fait
l'popé Coupe de France qui paraît
tellement loin maintenant tellement loin
et donc là les effets positifs de
saisons il y a deux saisons donc c'était
pas il a il y a pas si longtemps
finalement mais euh l'effet positif et
cette cette culture historique elle est
moins partagée sur le terrain j'imagine
que ça doit être souvent le cas dans ces
clubs de National où il doit y avoir
quand même beaucoup de turnover d'année
d'une année sur l'autre donc en effet on
est en perpétuel
reconstruction enfin ouais tous les tous
les ans donc et la mayonnaise doit
prendre tout de suite la mayonnaise doit
prendre tout de suite d'éléments fort de
l'effectif alors pas sur la saison
dernière mais Diego Michel c'est un peu
le le cœur technique de cette équipe
c'est vrai qu'au milieu de terrain il il
respirait voilà la technique ce joueur
on l'appréciait je sais tous les deux
Michel et diouba qui a souvent porté
aussi le brassard de capitaine qui était
un joueur très important de l'effectif
important aussi dans l'épopé Coupe de
France c'est lui qui avait inscrit le
but quasi qualificatif même s'il y a eu
une séance de tir au but derrière de
versaill face à Bergerac en quart de
finale donc c'est quand même aussi des
joueurs importants qui étaient déjà
important sur le terrain mais qui
pouvait aussi avoir un certain point
dans les vestiaires et il faut que
Versailles trouve de nouveaux leaders à
mon avis question il travaille il
travaille en paix en plus je par rapport
à l'année dernière au même moment où
est-ce qu' on les entendait c'était
toutes les semaines je ve dire dans les
ext sportifs on entendait là on là on
entend pas je veux dire c'est clair je
veux dire donc il je trouve qu'on il
travaille en paix et je trouve que c'est
bien après ils sont habitués ils étaient
tout nouveaux l'année dernière aussi
peut-être en étant promu peut-être
toutes les affaires qu'il y a eu voilà
un extra sportif c'est surtout ça ouais
ouais l'entraîneur ça étit arrivé au
bout de 2 mois de mémoire très vite he
dernière question est-ce que vous êtes
optimiste quand même pour Versailles
cette saison est-ce que vous les voyez
terminer dans un dans le top 5 on va
dire du class top 6 ah top 5 on pas
abuser non plus mais on va rester
Chauvin et on va souhaiter simplement
qu'il reste en National et qui n'aille
pas chercher la descente vous l'avez
vous l'aveiez dit tout à l'heure c'est
si descentes c'est énorme quand on
regarde quand on regarde le classement
en effet on est tout de suite très
proche de la descente Philip volac
dans les si prers dans les 6 premers
ouais ouais oua donc top 5 du coup
ou cétait c'était ma lueur d'espoir
après le après la réponse à la question
après chois dans la date ou pas c'est il
y a un calendrier sportif qui est qui
est présent qui est là euh ça joue pas
forcément en leur faveur pour l'instant
euh parce que la saison s'avance mais on
y est on on est oui optimiste quand
mêmeégor optimiste la faucheuse va
parler
euh non moi je les vois vraiment cette
saison
est ventre mou mais du coup se sauver en
National je les vois pas jouer plus
cette saison donc ils vont rester à peu
près dans la 8e 9e place pour vous donc
ils vont être champions de France de
National alors on continue à parler
football dans l'envolé de Grégory on
attend depuis des mois cet envolé alors
vous allez nous parler du campus PSG
grégoryi oui en juillet les footballeurs
du groupe pro du pariss-germain ont pris
leur nouveau quartier sur place un
campus de 74 hectares qui doit
accueillir à terme également l'équipe
féminine les titis du centre de
formation mais aussi les judoka et
handballeur parisiens d'ailleurs
l'inauguration officielle a été
repoussée au printemps 2024 dès cet été
nous avons pu découvrir en
avant-première ces nouvelles
installations et même même si la
circulation pour nous journalistes est
quelque peu compliquée sur place au sein
du bâtiment central qui est aussi un
lieu de vie pour les joueurs nos
premières impressions étaient plutôt
positives des terrains de grande qualité
de véritable billard comme on dit dans
le jargon mais aussi des équipements de
haute facture j'ai été pour ma part très
convaincu par l'espace de balnéo
thérapie l'envie de piquer une tête dans
les piscines n'a pas manqué à ce
moment-là le coach Louis Enrique
d'ailleurs adorerait l'endroit si sa
famille habite à Paris elle l'Espagnol a
décidé d'élire résidence à poissie dans
un appartement à proximité directe du
campus le matin il profite de la salle
de musculation pour s'adonner à quelques
exercices de renforcement musculaire et
de gainage suivi d'un petit footing ou
d'un tour à vélo un choix qui a surpris
tout le monde chez les salariés du club
d'autant que d'après nos confrères du
journal L'Équipe le nouveau centre
d'entraînement du PSG est loin de faire
l'unanimité en interne depuis
l'installation de l'état-major parisien
à poiss de nombreux problèmes ont été
identifiés une partie du mobilier est
jugé de piètre qualité plus gênant le
vent soufflerait fort et perturberait
les entraînements des joueurs mais aussi
la vie quotidienne sur place au point
même qu'il serait difficile d'avancer à
certains endroits du site lorsque le
vent arrive de face à cette
problématique venteuse s'en ajoute une
autre le président Nasser alrifi se
serait pleain du bruit oui du bruit
généré par le flux de l'autoroute à 1
qui passe seulement à quelques centaines
de mètres des des lieux ces révélations
de l'équipe ne sont peut-être que du
vent mais si ces informations sont avéré
ça soulève tout de même de nombreuses
questions pour un campus qui a coûté la
bagatelle de 250 à 300 millions d'euros
le choix d'un nouveau fief pour le club
de la capitale a pris plusieurs années
la piste tiverval grigon avait tenu la
corde avant d'être abandonné au profit
de poissie et la terrasse supérieure de
cet endroit qu'on appelle la ferme du
Poncy c'est là qui est implanté c'est
donc le centre d'entraînement personne
ne s'est rendu compte au moment des
études de faisabilité que le plateau
était exposé au vent cette donnée
n'aurait pas n'aurait pas dû être prise
en compte dans la conception du campus
pour protéger quelque peu les terrains
et je suis encore plus étonné de
l'argument du bruit ne pouvait-on pas
prévoir en amont que la présence d'une
autoroute comme la 13 qui est une voie
royale si je puis dire pour se rendre en
Normandie pour les Franciliens je pense
que vous confirmez autour de de la table
est-ce qu'on pouvait pas prévoir que
cette a 13 allait générer quelques
désagréments moi ça me laisse pant toi
tout toutes ces affaires autour du
parisgermain alors si le problème du
bruit peut se régler sans doute avec la
construction d'un mur du son pour celui
du vent ça semble plus compliqué déjà
que le PSG a du mal à battre ses
adversaires en Ligue des Champions
vaincre la nature et de l'ordre de
l'impossible votre réaction sur cette
magnifique envolée de Grégori le moment
fort je vous disais de cette émission
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Philip
volac moi déjà que vous a soupirer à
nombreuses repris ou ailleur non mais
bon je veux dire déjà avec kan sur les
accélérations il prennent des courants
d'air déjà donc
c'est voilà c'est peut-être ça aussi he
non bon il y a des trucs c'est pas c'est
pas normal et puis même que que le
président n'avait pas son bureau aussi
au début aussi il y a eu ça aussi que
son le Nasser n'avait pas son son bureau
mais bon je pense que ça va
être ça va être établi tout ça tout ça
va être va être établi c'est allez
quelques millions c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
grandchose he je veux dire 300 millions
ouais c'est pas c'est rien c'est rien
pour eux je veux dire peu plus cher
qu'un Neymar ouais bon je comprends pas
non plus c'est vrai comme disait Greg
qu'ils ont pas pris en compte ça dans
dès le départ je veux dire là 13 surtout
ça et puis même le même l'effet du
l'effet l'effet du vent je oui la 13
était bien présente avant le début des
travaux précise parce que le vent n'est
pas là tout le temps donc autant porte
le vent mais voilà mais bon voilà donc
mais bon ça va se rétablir et puis après
après les autres vont venir il va avoir
plus de monde il y aura moins de vent
peut-être s'il y a plus de monde donc
mais même les salariés ils disent que
quand ils ont le vent de face ils ont du
mal à avancer même les salariés donc
voilà ils le disent les
salariés chevalier une réaction et une
comparaison la réaction c'est c'est
quand même assez risible c'était c'est
inactu dans le dans le le cœur de l'été
bon c'est passé quand même un peu un peu
inaperçu en attendant on parle pas on
attend on parle pas du sportif on
pourrait parler du
début en poupe là-dessus on pourrait on
pourrait parler donc du sportif et du
début de saison du PSG avec de ce PSG
nouvelle formule qui aux yeux des
spécialistes et et en gros un PSG plus
authentique plus parisien plus
historique avec des jeunes avec avec un
recrutement moins flamboyant et avec
moins de tête d'affiche et un et un
nemmar toutpuissant qui qui a pas nymar
pardon voà oh là là l'absus l'sus très
révélateur euh un Mbappé tout puissant
qui a qui a les pouvoirs qui qui lui
sont conférés et qu'il mérite en
attendant la comparaison la comparaison
c'est c'est il y a juste à côté et
depuis très longtemps même moins
longtemps que la 13 mais depuis assez
longtemps un parcours de golf là qui est
qui est à bêemont juste juste à côté et
il y a pas trop de problème devent pour
y avoir joué là-bas il y a non il y
a oui justement et donc on est on n pas
décorné on n pas on n pas à faire des
trajecttoir bal un petit peu spécial
parce qu'il y a trop de vent donc bon a
priori c'est c'est c'est acceptable
comme condition yen gerier oui ben Paris
nous fera toujours rire voilà c'est tout
ce qu'on va pouvoir tout ce qu'on va
pouvoir dire là-dessus euh en effet
c'est quand on parle de budget de 300
millions je comprends pas que ces
chosesl soi pas anticipé un minimum on
voit que en effet c'est vrai que ça
manque pas mal d'armes moi si je prends
l'exemple de deux centres que tout le
monde connaît le CNR à marcousi bah
c'est vrai qu'on a la forêt et on est un
peu en encaissé si on prend CLIRE
fontaine on est en pleine forêt donc
c'est vrai que bah globalement quand on
va en forêt et les jours jours de
tempête il y a quand même moins de vent
quand on est en quand on est en foirêt
que quand on est dans une plaine donc
bah ouais c'était peut-être des choses
qu'il fallait qu'il fallait anticiper et
réfléchir réfléchir au départ mais euh
mais maintenant en effet ça va se régler
et puis bah ça fait de mois qu'ils y
sont et plus un peu plus le mois de
juillet juin fin juin donc cet été c'est
cet été ça mois de juillet il y a eu
quand même ça a bien soufflé septembre a
été quand même idylique pour pour tout
le monde au niveau de la météo là oui
depuis depuis 10 15 jours il y a un peu
de il y a un peu de vent donc oui si le
papier dans l'équipe est sorti cet été à
la période de juillet où en effet après
je crois dans mes souvenir qu'ils étent
en tourné asiatique sur le mois de
juillet avant le début la son le papier
auquel je faisais référence est même
sorti courant septembre courant
septembre ouais mais donc voilà
peut-être qu'il remis une couche et
peut-être qu'ils en ont parlé peut-être
qu' justement les les les les salariés
ont été surpris au mois de juillet de se
retrouver face au vent alors que c'est
une période qui a été où il y a eu de la
tempête tempête en sur sur les côtes sur
les côtes françaises bon voilà mais en
effet ce sera pas plus exposé de toute
façon que la région île-de-fance en
règle générale de toute façon la
question sur cette thématique est-ce que
ça ne fait pas trop caprice de star
finalement c'est c'est et c'est les
joueurs qui sont plein ou c'est les
salariés
du les salariés ce qu'on entendu les
salariés mais les joueurs sont les
salariés du club il y a pas eu de prise
de position officielle d'ailleurs sur la
question on parle bien ici de
d'information du journal L'Équipe oui ça
pourrait faire oui bon vous êtes unanime
sur la question est-ce que ça a vraiment
un impact du coup sur les performance
sportive le vent je sais pas Philippe
volac non non c'est une excuse c'est une
excuse ouais bah oui je veux dire t jou
au seul après ça les ça leur apprend à
jouer au sol donc voilà je veux dire
c'est tout je veux dire je trouve que
c'est une c'est une fausse excuse moi
j'ai pas trop entendu les joueurs s'en
plainre j'ai entendu Enrique s'en
plainre et et et le président et les
salariés qui ont dit bon donc ils sont
qu'on dit la même chose que le président
et que que Enrique mais voilà mais
pourquoi parce que Enrique lui quand il
quand il regarde les entraînements il
est sur une il est sur une grue donc il
est encore plus haut que encore donc en
fin de compte il a des prises prises
prises au vent je veux dire il regarde
il regarde super visice dans hauteur les
les comment donc voilà mais bon je
trouve que voilà fallait trouver quelque
chose je pense pour fallait trouver
quelque chose tout pouvait pas être
parfait du premier coup oui mais là
c'est pareil encore dans la
communication justement plutôt que dire
on vient deer dans notre nouveau et tout
se passe bien tout est beau tout est et
de laisser les petits détails de côté en
disant on va les régler c'est bon et il
y a pas de le mur antibruit ça gênera
personne de le faire de le faire faire
pour par rapport à la tresse c'est pas
c'est pas un gros gros problème ça
existe partout on envoit on envoie
toujours et et puis ben de d'aller
chercher le positif en disant on est
enfin rentré dans les dans les
infrastructures benant on va aller
appuyer sur des des broutill et en effet
encore une fois on passe pour des
clownes il reste 10 % à payer à
l'architecteali pour pour les nos yeux
de sportif amateurs d'autres sports et
de franilien surtout ça fait ça fait ça
donne une impression d'enfant gâté un
petit peu de de plus plus que de star
parce que surtout si c'est si c'est les
les salariés qui remontent ça c'est
peut-être aussi un une occasion de
d'avoir une pression sociale peut-être
sur les sur la manière dont se dont se
passe les conditions de travail pour
l'ensemble des des salariés du PSG mais
bon ça fait ça fait effectivement un
petit peu un petit peu désordre vu vu le
vu le le coût de l'investissement et et
et l'endroit choisi si on pense à la
comanderie si on pense à la Commanderie
pour Marseille qui est quand même sur
les hauteurs de Marseille avec la
tramontage ou la mistrale qui doit
souffler souffler très régulièrement je
pense que on en est quand même très très
loin en région parisienne dernière
question qu'est-ce qu'on peut le leur
conseiller refaire je sais pas refaire
le oui vous en décoration ce studio là
vous leur
proposez propos des services pour ça
pour le vent je pense que mal est fait
il fallait peut-être qu'oir si
effectivement il y a vraiment cette
problématique du vent peut-être que il
aurait fallu mieux protéger les terrains
je je ne sais pas je suis pas
spécialiste là-dessus euh pour le son
pour le bruit avec mon stylo qui tombe
le bruit qui a fait qui a fait justement
un petit un petit bruit bah peut-être
oui un mur du son je pense que c'est la
solution idéale ouis et c'est peut-être
pas facile non plus pour les pour les
journalistes qui viennent si si les
journalistes avec le quand tu quand tu
ouais quand tu tends le micro quand tu
fais des reportages tu devrais stir
alors Grégor justement vous qui es aller
dans ce centre d'entraînement du PSG
c'est la 14 c'est pas la 13 c'est la 14
qui il y a la 13 et la 14 la 13 elle est
elle est plus loin quand même non la 1
la 13 est dessus sur ouais sur les les
images qu'on a montré on la voit on la
voit la 13 en fond moi ce que j'en ai
pensé moi ça m'a pas gêné euh
personnellement c'est vrai que le flux
de voiture de la 13 on le sentait mais
personnellement Mo j'étais pas dans
l'entraînement donc ça me gênait pas
plus que ça le vent en revanche c'était
au mois de juillet il faisait super beau
donc j'avais pas de problématique devant
moi la seule chose moi qui est revenue
et que j'ai mis en avant dans dans l'
volé c'est que que j'ai mis en avant
dans l'envoler c'est que le bâtiment
central la la circulation pour les
journalistes est un peu difficile parce
que tout s passe il y a aussi bien les
joueurs qui ont leur vestia qui ont leur
quartier au dernier étage avec les
chambres et il y a l'étage consacré aux
journalistes et c'est vrai que pour
circuler dans ce bâtiment ah faut
montrer pas de Blanche hein c'est il y a
voilà quelqu'un nous accompagne dans
l'ascenseur c'est assez difficile de s'y
déplacer on peut même pas prendre
l'escalier oui après c'est normal c'est
normal on peut pas prendre l'escalier on
est obligé de prendre l'ascenseur donc
bon c'est vrai que la situation un peu
difficile après le niveau des
installations honnêtement moi ma
première impression c'est c'est qu'on
avait à faire quand même à des
installations de très bonne qualité avec
des des équipements vraiment à la pointe
on suivra en tout cas ce dossier avec
attention et on ne sait pas peut-être
que le problème du vent ou de
l'autoroute sera réglé dans dans les
prochains mois en tout cas
l'inauguration officielle de ce centre
d'entraînement est normalement programmé
pour le printemps pour l'instant pour
l'instant on n pas eu de de confirmation
exacte alors on va maintenant parler à
basket dans cette page basket on va
parler de ce phénomène Victor wemanama
Victor wemanama je dis son nom et ça
tombe bien il est ielinois puisqu'il a
commencé à l'entente le chîn Versailles
quand il était tout petit mais il était
déjà grand Victor 2 M23 a été drafté en
juin derniers par les San anonio Spurs
en première position une première pour
un Français depuis c'est la folie du
côté des États-Unis après une préaison
convainquante et une moyenne de 19,25
points 4,75 rebonds et
2,75 contes seulement
21,5 minutes de jeu il est aujourd'hui
très entendu par le monde du basket il
jouera son premier match dans la nuit de
ce mercredi à jeudi 26 octobre contre
les Dallas mavricks la question sur
cette thématique êtes-vous confiant pour
sa saison à quelques heures du début de
sa saison oui tout le monde est unanime
Yann vous qui aimez bien Victor Manama
euh moi j'ai préparé en lisant le le le
quotidien national hier parce qu'il y a
eu un gros il y a eu un beau pavé dessus
l'équipe non je je cite personne mainant
c'est fini je dis plus rienre de
l'équipe voilà le confère de l'équipe
tout à
fait sincèrement j'imaginais pas qu'il
jouerait aussi vite et au et avec un tel
impact en
effet je me suis dit en plus c'est un
peu la la philosophie des Spurs de de
laisser le temps de de les faire murir
et cetera et là se dire que sur les qure
matchs qu'il a déjà joué il a été
presque
décisif waouh je suis euh agréablement
surpris et bah j'ai hâte d'être parce
que je me lèverai pas ce ma cette nuit à
3h30 pour regarder le match ça c'est
clair et net mais j'ai hâte d'être
demain matin pour euh bah lire les
premiers les premiers articles alors ce
sera pas dans le dans le quotidien
demain matin mais euh de de pouvoir lire
les rapidement les les premières
impressions et et pouvoir voir le résumé
du match et et les et et c'est parce que
là euh ouais il y a une il y a une vraie
envie de de de le voir enfin évoluer
euh dans la NBA tout simplement
Grégory canalé je vous sens un peu ému
quand même de cette arrivée de
victiv on a suivi ces ces faits d'armes
à nan on parlait déjà de lui alors que
les médias nationaux s'y intéressaient
pas trop à
l'époque au au mets 92 à lavel aussi
juste avant et donc là de le voir ça y
est enfin foulerit les parquets de la la
NBA on a une attente on parlait de sa
draft voilà on a fait un peu le
comptearbour ici de Victor WEM banama on
n pas eu trop le choix dans la date sur
sur cette question mais on l'a attendu
en tout cas cette date avec impatience
donc vraiment très content de de le voir
moi je pense que oui il faut être
confiant lui en tout cas l'a beaucoup
quand on regarde sa déclaration
d'avantmch puisquil a été en conférence
de presse juste avant ce match face au
mavrix qui a lieu donc au moment où on
enregistre l'émission dans la nuit
prochaine voilà il a dit j'ai un peu des
papillons dans le ventre chez moi c'est
un peu le cas avant chaque match même si
ça dépend bien sûr des enjeux de
l'importance du match je ne me mets pas
à trembler à transpirer non plus mais
j'ai un peu mal au ventre donc on est un
peu dans cette philosophie du du gamin
qui n'a pas peur voilà la la phrase qui
qui s'affiche mais qui en même temps
voilà il vit son rêve de gamin il le dit
aussi dans cette interview dans cette
conférence de presse il est né presque
avec cette envie cette envie l'habite
depuis qu'il est qu'il est tout petit on
voit là dans ces premiers mois à au San
Antonio Spurs que bah il s'est quand
même acclimatisé euh déjà au niveau
musculaire il a pris entre 5 et 7 kg euh
pas pas de graisse comme moi hein mais 9
kg il a PR
al phipac su son régime mais visiement
je sais qu'il y a différentes sources
c'est comme sur sa taille est-ce qu'on a
est-ce qu'on a 2,23 2,24 il y a y a
différentes sources apparemment il
aurait été mesuré il est je crois au
niveau de la NBA à 2,26 ou 2,27 parce
qu' il mesure il mesure avec les
chaussures mesc
ch match et c'est plus impressionnant de
dire 2,27 c'est pour ça quand on suit là
son son acclimatation on a l'impression
de ça y est c'est le vrai texant il a
des photos il est avec son petit chapeau
de cowboy avec son petit son
petit petit taco voilà il a été adopté
par par par la population locale et
après moi j'ai envie dire ne comment
dire ne tirons pas forcément de
conclusion après ce premier match il y a
quand même 82 matchs en saison régulière
pour pour les équipes de NBA il va jouer
assez régulièrement attendons de voir ce
qu'il va donner c'est pas parce que il
est h fort cette nuit qui faudra dire
tout de suite ça y est il s'est bien
acclimaté et au contraire c'est pas
parce que il passe à côté de son match
qu'il faudra tout de suite le le
condamner il faut lui laisser le temps
de grandir et de s'acclimat ce
championnat de NBA Pierre Chevalier
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez B la
question c'est est-ce qu'on est confiant
pour sa saison donc là là on a tous été
unanime oui pour pour plein de raisons
le on le suit depuis très longtemps on
l'a tous rappelé de sur ce sur ce
plateau notamment et et on on sait
depuis le début qu'il est bien entouré
qu'il est bien entouré qu'il est qu'il a
eu la l'occasion les conditions pour
maturer alors déjà physiquement on l'a
laissé grandir on suivait on suivait en
gros àatoise sa sa croissance où il est
passé de 2 M20 et là avec les chaussures
à 2,27 dans tous les cas ça aolle ça
affolle les compteurs normalement 2,23
normalement voilà donc ça ça ça affolle
vraiment les compteurs et confiant aussi
sur la partie physique parce que parce
que c'est les États-Unis euh les la la
prise de poids en quelques semaines
c'est entre 7 et 9 on peut se demander
si les États-Unis ont la même ont les
mêmes règles que nous ou pas mais à
limite peu importe là il a passé
l'Atlantique et et maintenant il
commence à s'étoffer parce que c'était
peut-être souvenez-vous le le les les
points de vigilance qu'on avait en
disant une carcasse
pareille avec avec un physique assez frê
finalement donc très très long ligne et
assez frê c'est peut-être dangereux en
NBA avec les gros bras de de déménageurs
qu'il y a dans toutes les franchises
mais là en plus
ça va lui permettre de de s'affirmer
comme ce qu'il est c'estd un joueur
extrêmement complet moi ce qui ce qui me
ce qui me mes pates c'est ces stat
complètement complètement dingue de d'un
joueur qui qui est capable de shooter à
longue distance de prendre des de
prendre des rebonds et de bloquer de de
évidemment de dunker et de se matcher
dans dans la raquette doncon James a dit
de lui que c'était un alien il a dit ça
donc forcément il a de la pression
Libron James qui qui est là C cette
saison le le plus vieux joueur de de la
de la
NBA on peut lui faire confiance sur
justement sur sur l'expertise par
rapport au joueurs qui arrivent premier
de la draft en France c'est déjà déjà
assez historique et en plus a priori je
pense qu'on va le voir on va le voir en
haut des en haut des tableaux de stat et
peut-être que peut-être que San anonio
va va revenir au premier au premier plan
grâce à grâce à W gr mais mais justement
est-ce qu'il a pas trop de pression tout
monde l' attend les fans de San anonio
l'attendent avec impatience il y a eu le
sport le média sportif américain ESPN
qui le place d'ors et déjà la 47e place
des meilleurs joueurs de la NBA dans son
top 100 alors qu'il n'a jamais joué un
match en NBA il le place devant des
joueurs comme Russell West Brook par
exemple qui a qui a sillonné les
parquets de NBA pendant toutes ces
années il y a eu le coach de Miami Eric
spelstra qui a dit il fait il fait à mes
joueurs ce que je faisais à mon fils de
5 ans la semaine dernière donc forcément
tout le monde enthousiasme pour lui
est-ce qu'il a pas trop de pression
justement est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
est bien préparé Philippe si il en a de
la pression parce que même l'entraîneur
poovic qui est frileux devant les les
médias d'habitude il est très frileux là
il est vraiment émerveillé devant il
s'est dit rassuré il avait peur il
voulait pas le mettre en avant et là
maintenant qu'il l'a vu évoluer préparé
ris c'est vraiment c'est impressionnant
et puis quand il a tout la pression on
voit Dallas il vont jouer contre Dallas
Dallas il s'entraîne avec des
extensions de BR
vrara extensions dire et c'est c'est
incroyable quand on a vu même quand ils
font l'engagement je ve dire acur
dernièrement le dernier match accur je
veux dire il récupère le ballon déjà ils
sont s de
récup bat bien mais B Mme il un avantage
avant et puis il y a pas que ça il y a
aussi il y a aussi les places et tout je
dire là il se revend les bord terrain
pour le match là le prochain match cette
nuit là 6000 enfin presque 6000 dollars
6000 dollars la place que ça se
revendait sur la plateforme c'est c'est
incroyable pour lui Grégory et je pense
aussi l'excitation de le voir enfin
évoluer en NBA c'est que sur les matchs
de la Summer League de préssaison il a
souvent évolué face à des seconds
couteau si je puis dire là on va enfin
le voir bah la nuit prochaine il y aura
Irving il y aura peut-être un DONIC qui
est qui est uncertain face face à lui
mais Philippe parlait de de exemple de
ces bras qui ont été utilisés ces
extensions de bras pour pour s'entraîner
voilà aux éventuels compes qui pourrait
pourrait faire de Dallas bah ça monre
qui va être je pense scruté qui va être
un peu une cible ça va être je dis pas
l'homme à abattre cette saison mais je
pense que chaque équipe va être vraiment
impatiente de de l'affronter et je pense
qu'il y a d'autres enjeux c'est est-ce
qu'on je disais tout à l'heure il y a il
y a plus de 80 matchs est-ce qu'il va
être capable de gérer cette fatigue cet
enchaînement des matchs et aussi bah de
faire face à la pression méditi parce
que vous disiez mich aux États-Unis tout
est amplifié c'est même pas FO 10 c'est
FO 1000 au ÉtatsUnis très rapidement
vous demandez si il est préparé pour ça
je veux dire ça fait des années que on
sait qu'il va y aller donc lui
aujourd'hui il est juste dans son
cheminement dans son plan dans son
cheminement il y a pas de il y a pas de
crainte à avoir et et en plus là Popovic
est rassuréut faut pas oublier vous disz
aujourd'hui ils ont déjà dit il sera à
chaque il parlera après après chaque
match le gamin il a 20 ans il a 20 ans
c'est dire que c'est lui 19 ans je crois
il a même
pas voilà mais il va les avoir il va les
avoir il va avoir 20 ans donc je suis
pas très loin mais voilà il a 20 ans et
c'est lui qui va faire le débrief alors
qu'il vient juste d'arriver quoi donc
voilà le gamin il a la tête sur les
épaules c'est la star
et il va démontrer tout ce qu'on attend
la seule chose que j'espère qu'il
n'arrivera pas ce serait une blessure
qui pourrait être qui pourrait lui être
fatal à un moment ou un autre c'est
vraiment le seul point
qui c'est pour tout le monde voilà c'est
le pépin physique qui pourrait en ni
fait briser briser briser une car non
j'ai commencé par ça je le souhaite pas
parce que c'est vraiment ça qui qui
pourrait qui pourrait être mais
apparemment le reste est maîtrisé dans
son jeu dans son esprit dans sa dans sa
façon d'être c'est génial en tout cas
vous l'avez compris autour de cette
table on est tous très excités par
l'arrivée de Victor wanema en NBA on le
suivra avec attention et on débriefera
ses premiers matchs dans le prochain si
on parle les sports on va maintenant
parler des Jeux olympiques de 2024 avant
de clôturer cette émission et plus
précisément de la colline d'élancour qui
va accueillir les épreuves de VTT
pendant le rendez-vous pour se préparer
pour l'événement un Test Event a été
organisé fin septembre avec tous les
sportifs internationaux de la discipline
sur le site plus de 5000 personnes dont
3000 spectateurs un vrai avantgoût des
Jeux Olympiques on écoute Tony stanguer
le président de Paris 2024 une mine
d'information très très importante pour
nous qui seront débriefé là dans les
prochains jours globalement les
indicateurs sont au verts le site il est
il est très chouette il plaît aux
athlètes il va y avoir de très très
belles compétition l'année prochaine on
repart avec beaucoup d'énergie on sait
qu'il reste encore beaucoup de travail
dans les 10 mois qui viennent mais
globalement on repart quand même avec
plus de de sérénité à l'issue de ce test
une belle journée sur le plan sportif
également pour les français chez les
dames Luana le compte termine première
de cette compétition amicale et Pauline
Ferrand préveau monte sur la 3oème
marche du podium chez les hommes Victor
koretski termine également premier la
question sur cette thématique un premier
test réussi sur la colline des lancour
oui ou non vous
votez oui pour tout le monde bien du
jarier vous qui êtes le spécialiste
cyclisme qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
était pas trop non peut était pas trop
mais connaissant un petit peu le site il
y avait peu de chance que ça se passe
mal alors je dis pas que ça se passe mal
pour les Français juste que
l'organisation et que le parcours soit
pas en réponse aux attentes voilà il y
avait tous les ingrédients qui était qui
était mis en place et pour pouvoir faire
un beau site pour pour un pour une pour
un circuit olympique là-dessus pas de
pas pas d'inquiétude il y avait ouais
tout est tout est réuni je pense même
que c'est parfois plus boisé que
certaines Coupe du monde qu'on peut
avoir en montagne donc moi je y avait
tout ce qu'il fallait suffisamment
dénivelé apprécié ouais ouais c'est
c'était c'était c'était assez ouais
ouais c'est sympa j'étais pas dispo ce
weekend là pour pouvoir m'y rendre mais
en effet j'ai vu les images et en effet
on a on a une belle une belle course
Seris sur le gâteau les Français gagnent
le le test le Test Event moi j'aurais
préféré l'inverse qui se rate et puis ça
veut dire quelque chose ou pas pour vous
qui gagne cette épreuve à quelques mois
des
j euh ça veut juste dire que le parcours
leur convient et et après je dirais la
même chose pour pour les triathlètes
puisqu'on a eu le Test Event même s'ils
ont pas eu la la la partie pcine enfin
la partie natation quand il quand il y a
eu le Test Event sur sur Paris c'est
toujours bien de marquer euh de marquer
les adversaires en disant les gars moi
ça me convient ici et je serai présent
je serai présent dans un an maintenant
c'est dans un an et il peut se passer
plein de choses dans une année euh comme
je disait pour pour Victor là c'est la
même chose une blessure une blessure
malencontreuse et ben fait que vous êtes
pas en forme le jour J là on parle de la
course d'un jour Pauline ferrant préau
aura encore plus la pression que que
d'habitude parce que ce sera ses ce
seront ses derniers jeux et qu'elle en a
déjà raté deux euh je sais même plus si
elle est revenue avec une médaille du du
Japon mais mais je suis je suis pas sûr
et alors qu'elle est euh cinq fois
championne du monde championne du monde
et vous dites bah ouais il manque un
truc et sur ce type de sport alors on
pas parler de sport de disciplines qui
sont un peu plus anonymes
que que le cyclisme sur route tout le
tour de France ben en effet il faut être
champion olympique pour pouvoir sortir
du pour pouvoir sortir du LOU alors que
pour moi Paulin fer préo qui a été la
première à avoir trois titres de
champion du monde la même année dans
trois sports dans dans trois disciplines
différentes c'était déjà énorme Grégor
can qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
réussite sportive je vais pas en dire
plus par rapport à aen ça ça ça ne fait
aucun doute ça montre aussi que les
sportifs français ont du talent et sans
pression sont capables d'aller remporter
ce ce genre de compétition maintenant on
va voir effectivement avec Paris 2024 si
la pression qui sera à mon avis à son
compte va pas les déstabiliser point de
vue organisationnel grosse réussite
aussi par qu'on parle ici d'un Test
Event alors on était pas totalement en
formule Joo encore parce que là on était
sur du 3000 spectateurs pendant les Jos
on parle plutôt de 20000 personnes qui
se rendront sur place avec des tribunes
qui seront montées un peu partout aussi
ça bah ça a permis de se rendre compte
que ce qui avait été fait au niveau de
la piste c'est vrai que moi pour avoir
déjà été sur le le site de la colline de
la revanche avant et après elle a été
quasiment métamorphosé on ne reconnaît
même pas moi je trouve certains endroits
de de la colline donc de ce point de vue
là il y a vraiment eu un très beau
travail qui a été fait et ça permet
aussi de se rendre compte du travail qui
reste à accomplir parce que je pense
effectivement que toutes les zones pour
les spectateurs vont nécessiter encore
un peu de travail parce que je quelques
problèmes au niveau de la gestion des
flux d'après les les les premiers les
premiers commentaires au niveau de la
gestion des flu surtout qu'il y aura
plus de spectateurs pour les Jos 2024
c'est vrai que les abords directs de la
piste il y a certains endroits où
c'était vraiment très très serré je
pense qu'il y a peut-être un petit
travail encore à faire là-dessus mais on
parlait bien ici de test even donc
l'idée c'est de se tester et de faire le
point aussi sur ce qui reste à faire et
de ce point de vue là on ne peut parler
on peut ne parler que de d'événement
réussis Pierre Chevalier pour les sujets
vélo qui me tiennent vraiment à cœur moi
je ferai un raisonnement par l'absurde
un peu comme comme le PSG et son centre
d'entraînement vaut mieux qu'il se
rendent compte maintenant que c'est
adapté que c'est un bon lieu et que
c'est bien organisé que que en juillet
ou août
pas qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez test sachant que bah les quotas
ils sont ils sont faibles je crois que
c'est deux deux comment deux Françaises
et deux Français qui
pourrontire ouais donc ça va être un peu
ça va être pour toutes les nations et
puis je crois qu'en fin de compte ils
reviennent plus sur le circuit avant
juillet avant juillet 2024 donc je crois
que c'est ça dans dans dans un an enfin
à peine un an Mo je dire les Français
n'ont pas droit de s'entraîner sur sur
le site pour une question d'équité et
ils disent que bon j'ai entendu parler
du du circuit disait qu'il était très si
tu tu as une déconcentration même pas de
2 secondes ou 3 secondes tu perds tu
perds le tu perds la course très
technique très tonique ouais ouais c'est
c'est voilà donc j'ai hâte de voir ça
alors les épreuves de VTT sont
organisées les 28 et 29 juillet lors des
Jeux olympiques de 2024 et d'ici là on a
compris les organisateurs vont encore
peaufiner cette colline d'lancour alors
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission de
cette première émission de l'année on va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui je vous propose une
citation de l'ancien basketteur Michael
Jordan en référence à Victor wanama il
faut se fixer des buts avant de pouvoir
les atteindre je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phrase à bientôt sur
[Musique]
tv78